an armed man is holding employees
hostage at a federal bank in lebanon's
capital beirut he's demanding his own
money and threatening to burn down the
bank security forces have not yet
entered the building well for more on
this let's bring in zaina hoda in beirut
first of all can you explain what the
latest is and why he's holding hostages
just to get his own money out
well it is a tense situation and armed
man is inside that building the federal
a bank he's holding hostages employees
and citizens an unknown number i must
say they're believed to be at least six
a short while ago we saw an elderly man
leave the building the government
negotiator is trying to convince him to
lay down his arms in fact even his
brother has been brought in and we saw
his brother try to speak to him through
the gates now yes this man is demanding
his own money because for the past three
years lebanon's commercial banks have
imposed informal capital controls uh
trapping people's savings
inside the banks people are not able to
access their money and especially dollar
accounts
when you withdraw money there's limits
on withdrawals and they disperse the
money in the local currency which has
devalued and they don't even give it to
the depositors at the market rate so an
unofficial haircut if you like people
deprived from their savings this man is
saying he wants his money two hundred
and ten thousand us dollars he's been
visiting the bank in recent days
demanding five thousand dollars in order
to be able to pay for his father's
hospital bill he doesn't have a job and
um he believes that this is rightfully
his so a tense situation this is not an
armed robbery if you like an armed bank
robbery in the full sense of the word
but this is a man taking hostages in the
bank demanding what he believes is
rightfully
his
indian this isn't the first time this
has happened in lebanon is it
no a few months ago a depositor in the
east of the country also um stormed a
bank armed held employees hostages and
demanded 50 000 of his money he was
given the money but then he was arrested
people are desperate more than 80
percent of the population is now poor uh
three years of an economic crisis and
yet the politicians those who have been
running and governing this country for
decades have done nothing really to
reverse the economic collapse they
haven't approved an economic recovery
plan they're not passing the laws needed
in order for an imf bailout package in
order to be um
eligible for dollars you see people are
angry these are other depositors who
have come to support
the man inside saying what he is doing
is the right thing because they've tried
through legal means they've
they've held protests they've demanded
politicians force banks to
give them their money but banks argue
that they lent the money to the state
which is now bankrupt and unless the
state pays them the money then they
cannot give the depositors any money
incredible scenes there thank you very
much that zaina hoda in beirut for us